well we live in a big city with a whole
lot of light so if you want to see the
stars
either head to the strip to see the
celebrity kind or you have to head out
of town to get away from all the lights
or you have another option you can take
a drive over to csn's planetarium
which is back open following coveted
closures 8 news now reporter
victoria saha is there live this morning
to show us
all around such good news that they're
back open good morning victoria
good morning sherry we are outside in
the observatory part of the planetarium
over here we have different domes where
there's telescopes inside that you can
see the moon different planets pretty
neat experience
joining me now is manager andrew kerr
hello um you guys have been closed for
such a long time since the pandemic
what can folks expect when they walk in
all right well we're back to our normal
public show schedule we have shows at
six
seven and eight o'clock on friday and
saturdays as well as a 3 30 show on
saturday afternoons it's six dollars for
adults five dollars for kids
but we also have a special going on
right now where you can rent the whole
theater monday through friday at either
9 30 or 11 a.m
bring as many folks as you want get to
choose your own show and have your own
private theater experience
for our astronomy enthusiast there is
something happening in the skies in the
next couple of weeks correct
oh yeah we've got a lot going on we've
got saturn reaching opposition which
means it's going to be up all night and
at its closest approach
so it's going to be a good time to be
looking for that jupiter follows about
an hour later
so it's coming into opposition as well
and then august 11th and 12th if you're
out in the early morning hours
before the sun rises look up in the sky
you might get a chance to see a few of
the perseid meteors streak through there
thank you so much i know the sun's out
right now but once you walk inside you
feel like it's the middle of the night
it's pretty neat experience again
that 50 until august 31st will get you a
full
private rental of the theater for the 9
30 and 11 o'clock shows
and then friday and saturday six dollars
reporting live at victoria saha 8 news
now